من يتابع السياسه الخارجيه التركيه منذ ان
جاء حزب العداله والتنميه في 2002 و2003
يستطيع ان يقسم الى 20 سنه الماضيه تقريبا
الى ثلاثه محطات رئيسيه المحطه الاولى من
2003 ل 2013 وتستطيع ان تصف السياسه
الخارجيه لتركيا في هذه السنوات العشر
بكلمتين فقط دون اخلال كبير زيرو مشاكل من
صاغ هذه الاستراتيجيه وماذا تعني ساقها
احمد داوود اوغلو احد اقطاب حزب العداله
والتنميه
وتولى وزاره الخارجيه ثم رئاسه الوزراء
قبل ان ينشق عن الحزب وينضم الى المعارضه
مؤخرا المقصود بزيرو مشاكل ان تكون تركيا
دوله فاعله ومؤثره بدون استخدام قوه
عسكريه او قوه خشنه في كل المناطق الحيويه
لتركيا اسيا الوسطى اوروبا منطقه الشرق
الاوسط حين جاء حزب العداله والتنميه كانت
تركيا تعاني من معضله هذه المعضله انها
دوله كما قال احمد داوود اوغلو تتمتع
بعضلات قويه لكن تاثيرها محدود جدا في
المناطق الحيويه لتركيا اراد ان يعزز نفوذ
تركيا وتاثيرها وبالتالي مصالحها كيف يمكن
ان يفعل ذلك بزياده القوه الناعمه وما هي
القوه الناعمه
هي ان تجبر الاخرين على ان يمتثلوا لما
تريد دون ان تستخدم القوه الخشنه وكيف
يمكن ان تتمتع بقوه ناعمه ان تكون مثلا
يحتذى محبوبا تهوي اليك الافئده وتحب ان
تحاكيك وتقترب منك وتتعاون معك دون
استخدام القوه القصريه لذلك كيف فعلت
تركيا ذلك فعلته باتباع مجموعه كبيره من
السياسات بدءا من الدراما التي تصور تركيا
على انها بلد يعني عظيم وجميل وجذاب
ويستحق الزياره الى يعني مستويات مختلفه
مثلا بدات فعلا في اتخاذ اجراءات
مهمه لتكون دوله اكثر ديمقراطيه دوله
قانون ادخلت اصلاحات اقتصاديه كبيره
طبعا ده كان احد اهدافه ايضا الانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي هل ما فعلته تركيا منذ
2003 والعشر سنوات التاليه كان امرا فريدا
غير مسبوق في العالم ابدا دول اخرى فعلى
ذلك ولكن ما كان مختلفا في تركيا ان هذه
الاصلاحات الديمقراطيه والاقتصاديه تمت
تحت حكومه ذات توجهات اسلاميه الامر الذي
جذب اهتمام عدد كبير من الدول العربيه
والدول الاسلاميه على الاقل على مستوى
الشعوب لانها رات ان هناك املا في ان تكون
هناك دوله اسلاميه وقادره على ان تقترب من
تحقيق النموذج الديمقراطي قادره على ان
تحقق اقتصادا مزدهرا العالم الغربي تابع
التجربه التركيه باهتمام لانه كان سعيدا
ان يرى حكومه تقول انها اسلاميه ولكنها
صديقه للغرب صديقه لاسرائيل
راغبه في ان تكون جسرا بين الشرق والغرب
ثم اتبع التركيه مجموعه اخرى من السياسات
لازاله الاحتقانات زيرو مشاكل تعني ان
تصفر مشاكلك مع دول الجيران فان عجزت عن
تسفير المشاكل فلتجعل المشكلات والمتاعب
في اقل مساحه ممكنه وبدات تفعل ذلك او
تحقق ذلك من خلال ازاله الاحتقانات
والدهائن التاريخيه مع الكرد مع الارمن
بدات تحسن العلاقات مع دول كانت علاقتها
متوتره مع تركيا لسنوات طويله سوريا روسيا
بدات تلعب دور الوساطه في نزاعات حساسه
حولها لعبت دور الوساطه بين اسرائيل
وسوريا بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين بين
ايران والولايات المتحده
الداخلي في 2013 شهدت حكومه اردوغان لاول
مره احتجاجات مناهضه لحكومته الرجل كان
يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره لكن في 2013 اندلعت
مظاهرات واشهر هذه المظاهرات هي المظاهرات
جيزي وما هي جيزي هي حديقه حدائق موجوده
في ميدان اسمه تقسيم على ما اعتقد وهذه
الحدائق ارادت الحكومه في 2013 ان تزيلها
وتبني عليها مول تجاري كبير احتج بعض
النشطاء او المؤيدين للبيئه او غير
المستفيدين من المشروع فقررت الشرطه
ابعادهم تجمع مزيد من المحتاجين استخدمت
الشرطه مزيدا من الاجراءات العنيفه
فانتشرت الاحتجاجات مثل الناري في الهشيم
في عشرات المدن واحتاجت الحكومه التركيه
اكثر من اسبوعين للسيطره على هذه
الاحتجاجات
ان تتراجع عن القرار واسفرت الاحتجاجات عن
عدد من القتلى حوالي 8000 جريح مئات
المعتقلين ووقتها قال اردوغان ان من يقف
وراء هذه الاحتجاجات ليس مجرد محتاجون
يعني ذوي نوايا بريئه او بسيطه ولكنها قوى
تسعى للطعامر على تركيا في نفس الفتره بدا
يظهر للعلم خلافات كانت تعتمر في الخفاء
بين حزب العداله والتنميه والسيد اردوغان
وفتح الله جولان وحركه الخدمه فتح الله
جولان رجل دين ذو تاثير كبير يقيب الانف
الولايات المتحده وكان صديقا او استاذا
لاردوغان وكان دعمه
وحركته حركه الخدمه مؤثر في شعبيه اردوغان
وفي وصوله الى السلطه ولكنه مختلف الاسباب
طول شرحها
وبدا الخلاف يظهر الى العالم والسيد فتح
الله جولان هو من اتهمه اردوغان بالضلوع
هو وحركته في محاوله الانقلاب الفاشله
عليه في منتصف يوليو 2016
هذا على المستوى الداخلي على المستوى
الدولي كانت هناك متغيرات اخرى كثيره 2013
مقارنه ب 2003 الولايات المتحده اصابها
الاجهاد من حروبها الطويله في الشرق
الاوسط بعد حوالي 12 سنه بدات الحروف في
2001 ونحن وصلنا 2013 في افغانستان العراق
الحرب على الارهاب وارادت ان تتراجع وبدات
تترجم سياستها الراغبه في الانسحاب من
مناطق ومنها منطقه الشرق الاوسط والا تلعب
فيه دورا فاعلا وهذا تحدثنا عنه قبل ذلك
كثيرا وساضع لحضراتكم الروابط التي تحدثنا
فيه عن هذه السياسه التركيه السياسه
الامريكيه في نفس الوقت بدات تنشط دول
اخرى في مناطق حيويه لتركيا مثل الصين
مثل روسيا سواء في الشرق الاوسط او في
اسيا الوسطى الى اخره وظهرت المشاكل اكثر
بين تركيا وبين الاتحاد الاوروبي وبدا
واضحا للسيد اردوغان ان حلمه بالانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي لن يتحقق ابدا لكن كان
اهم عامل ادى لتغيير السياسه الخارجيه
التركيه من زيرو مشاكل الى زيرو اصدقاء هو
بدء انكسار مشروع ثورات الربيع العربي في
اذكر حضراتكم انه ثورات الربيع العربي كما
تعلمون بدات تندلع بدايه من 2000
ومنذ ان اندلعت راى فيها السيد اردوغان
فرصه عظيمه للدوله التركيه وراى ان هذه
فرصه حتى تسقط كل الانظمه التي كانت قائمه
وقتها لتحل محلها انظمه اخرى تتشكل او
تاتي من جماعات ذات توجهات اسلاميه ومنها
او على راسها جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وهذه
التيارات والجامعات سوف تشكل احزابا على
غرار حزب العداله والتنميه وتصبح انقره هي
عاصمه العالم السني كله
الناس التركي القطري الامريكي كان هناك
شعور بالقلق الشديد خصوصا في دول الخليج
اللي كانت متماسكه لم تتاثر كثيرا بثورات
الربيع العربي هذه الدول رات في هذا
المخطط تهديد للانظمه الحاكمه هناك وقررت
ان تبدا ثوره مضاده لثورات الربيع العربي
وكان اول مواجهه بين المعسكرين تركيا قطر
وجماعه اخوان المسلمين والدول الخليج كان
على الاراضي المصريه في 2013 وانتهى
بالاطاحه بجامعه الاخوان المسلمين وفد
اعتصامي النهضه ورابعه وبدا من ذلك الوقت
استخدام علامه رابعه وكان اردوغان الزعيم
الوحيد الذي يستخدم هذه العلامه تعبيرا عن
ادانته لما حدث في مصر وتاييدا او تعبيرا
عن دعمه لهذه الجماعه التي يعتقد البعض
انه ينتمي اليها
على العموم زاد التوتر بين المعسكرين
خصوصا بعد يوليو 2016 عندما تعرض اردوغان
لمحاوله انقلاب اتهم
حركه الخدمه بالوقوف وراءها ولكن
قال مسؤولون اتراك ان دول اخرى تورطت في
هذا الانقلاب وبعضهم المح تحديدا الى دوله
الامارات على كل الاحوال تحول الصراع بين
المعسكرين الى صراع مفتوح على كل ساحات
دول المنطقه بل بلا مبالغه دول العالم كان
الصراع موجودا في
ليبيا كان الصراع موجودا في البحر الاحمر
كان موجودا في اليمن كان موجودا في البحر
المتوسط كان موجودا في العواصم الاوروبيه
وفي كواليس واشنطن كل معسكر بيحاول ان
يقوم بعمليه او ضغط واقناع للدول المؤثره
حتى يقتربها يقت ربها الى صفهم على العموم
السياسه زيرو اصدقاء التي اتبعها اردوغان
من 2013 وحتى
2020-2021 استجابه للتحديات الجديده ادت
في نهايه المطاف الى نتيجتين اساسيتين
بقطع النظر عن ما انتصر ومن خسر يعني هذا
الصراع هذه قصه يطول شرحها لكن نتج عنه
نتيجتين اساسيتين واحد انه الاقتصاد
التركي اصيبه بكثير من الاجهاد ونحن
تحدثنا اكثر في اكثر من حلقه عن متاعب
الاقتصاد التركي
ومتاعب الاقتصاد التركي هي ناتجه في
الحقيقه عن ما يشبه العزله السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه التي فرضت على تركيا لماذا
عاشت تركيا في ما يشبه العزله الدبلوماسيه
والسياسيه لان سياسته زيرو اصدقاء اللي هي
يعني محاوله استخدام الدبلوماسيه الخشنه
والتدخل العسكري
لمحاوله درء الاخطار التي راها تحيط به من
وضعته في صدام ليس فقط مع دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط ولكن مع دول اوروبيه كثيره وضعته
في صدام في بعض الملفات مع الولايات
المتحده وضعته في علاقه متوتره وملتهبه
وان كانت خافته مع روسيا وايران واذكر
حضراتكم من الان ان العلاقه اذا استمرت
السياسه التركيه على ما هو عليه واستمرت
الاوضاع كما هي في روسيا وايران اخذه الى
الصدام وسوف تكون العلاقه بين تركيا من
ناحيه وبين روسيا تحديدا وايران ايضا في
حاله صدام متصاعد في السنوات المقبله
اراد السيد اردوغان بعد بسبب هذا الاجهاد
الاقتصادي والعزله
الدبلوماسيه وتدني شعبيتهم مقارنه
بالسنوات الاولى من حكمه الامر الذي يهدد
فرسه بالفوز في انتخابات 2023 خصوصا مع
تكتل المعارضه ضده املا في استغلال هذا
التراجع في الشعبيه والتراجع الاقتصادي
للفوز عليه في 23 اراد ان يعيد النظر في
السياسات الخارجيه الهدف انه يخفف حده
التوتر مع دول الجوار وبالتالي
تنكسر العزله الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه
وبالتالي تتدفق الاستثمارات كما كانت
تتحسن الاوضاع تكون فرصته في الانتخابات
والفوز فيها اكبر العام المقبل
ابرز ملامح المرحله الجديده التي بدات
تتشكل في
2020-2023 محاوله التهدئه مع كل دول
الجوار
يعني اراد السيد اردوغان ان يعود سيرته
الاولى الى سياسه زيرو مشاكل التي بداها
بنجاح من 2003 ل 2013